we're trying to create a community of
uh with pi data so i um as such we've
created also a slab group
which is uh separate and
we can we can throw the link in in the
chat and you can join
if you want to be more active outside
the
meetup and and we also hope that
i mean we want to continue being able to
do this re
this remote friendly events but we hope
also that
very soon we will be able to do to
resume doing these meetups
in a physical location so maybe we can
all meet together and
and watch this uh the next the next
method
cool so i'm going to check my screen and
i'm just going to very briefly tell you
about non-focus in case you
haven't heard the which is the umbrella
organization behind pi data
focus is a non-profit that sponsors a
lot of the projects
behind the tools that you probably use
on your day-to-day some of which are
here in the screen like pandas numpy
and and so on and so forth there are a
couple of projects
uh in the numpy family and one of the
initiatives that
nam focus runs is by data
by data i don't know where it started
but has grown to a global phenomenon so
it uh
like there are more there are 186 groups
in
in a lot of countries i was part of pi
data in london
chris was in berlin but you know we're
very lucky to have my data here in
cyprus as well
which is um what we're uh what we're
here for today
um and i guess with that i just
want to um pass it over to constantinos
i guess
all right
so let me share my screen i will not
keep you long
just a couple of minutes to introduce
zoom uh basically let me see
how do i share
share screen
okay so
the today's topic can you see my screen
basically yes right
yes okay so today's topic
is very important for an organization
like ours
we started we started off at 2011.
um me and so there is basically
kick off the company 10 years ago
and our main focus was on big data
we've been writing mostly sodium is
basically
has been writing code since
we switched languages and
packages quite a few times
and along this journey
starting off with statistics and
thinking that statistics is the only
thing that we
need to be involved with we have to
compromise a few things
in order to make sure that our results
are presented in the right way
so one of the most important things
that we will also share today is that
how exactly we need to use the these
algorithms about
exceptional stores exceptional data
outlier detection techniques how we we
took even projects that we wrote
five or six years ago when we
took a different turn in the last few
years
so we are dealing with a lot of data
in all these countries and
[Music]
actually in the last few years it has
saved
a lot of time and money to the company
when this alcohol is performed
and when we detect uh
outliers whether these are coming from
human errors most of the times
on purpose people try to cheat
we have mistakes from miscommunications
or
from electronic data
structures so being present in more than
20 countries
like i said it's very crucial for us to
have this as alphas in place and
make sure that we let's say
track as many of these outliers as
possible so in the first part we will
show
paulina will show something that we
wrote specifically
for a case of supermarkets and some
different applications on
[Music]
on various industries that we have and
then andreas will
speak for the uh part of the churn uh
model
which we used in order to
[Music]
detect outlying behavior in among
shoppers okay so
i will pass on to to bolina
hello everyone just a second to
share my screen
are you able to see my screen
yes thank you so
uh my name is paulina and i work here at
retail zoom
as a data scientist and as constantino
said
the concept today is to talk about
outlier detection
this is an overview of today's agenda
and i'll start off with
the purpose of this event
the purpose for this event is to share
with you
our experience on how we manage to
tackle
a variety of business problems using
outlier detection solutions more
specifically we will show you
two of our currently running projects
the approach we followed
and of course some codes for the one
problem that i will present we use
simple statistics
and for the other one we use machine
learning
the key lesson we learned throughout
this process
uh was that finding an outlier is not
enough
for me personally as a data scientist
this was weird because as data
scientists we focus on finding the most
accurate
pro model the most precise model
in order to detect those outliers but as
a business
our ultimate goal is to support
our end users our clients in order to
get
all the necessary insights from those
outliers
so let's move on uh with an introduction
of
what an outlier detection is
in order to define the outline detection
we have to give a definition
for the outliers the outliers are data
points
that either under or over perform
compared to the expected norm
also there is a variety of techniques
that can be used
in order to detect them
also depending on on your
concept a different technique and
approach might be used
if you want to find an outlier in order
to remove it from your data
to clean your data and then use this as
an input in your machine learning in
order to have an accurate model
and a different approach will be used if
you want to find
the outliers and then investigate them
further
outlier detection the last few years has
a has seen
a rise in a lot of industries
and for example let me give you a real
life
application in healthcare
[Music]
i don't know if you are aware but last
year
it was made public that three
ophthalmologists
abused the cyprus national healthcare
system
by charging it 2 million euros
actually the algorithm worked correctly
because
that amount was very huge and not very
common
to other ophthalmologists but was
their focus only on that actual number
was enough
because a different approach and action
will be taken
if the two millions were coming from two
million procedures costing one euro
and a different action would be taken if
actually
two procedures were performed and only
and cost
one million each so always the concept
and your goal
matters another example is in banking
usually banks have a threshold
on the daily transactions in order to
flag
some red flags to the bankers to
investigate them further
let's say for example they have a
threshold of
500 euros and a person made a
transaction of
10 000 euros correctly they are
algorithms we flag this
as a typical value but just focusing on
the actual number is it enough
no because it will matter if that
10 000 were coming from a person that
frequently made this high amount
transactions
and a different action should be taken
from the bank if the amount came from
someone
that had um 1 000
as a salary and his average transactions
let's say
100. so again
finding an outlier is not enough you
have
to see all the information and all the
reasons that
cause them to be an outlier
moving on let's see some of our
own business projects
first of all we have the sales and
price correction project
this is a monthly project where we try
to estimate
the market share of
a specific chain for the products that
they sell
the order we collect their own data is
through manual transaction
so we use and build an algorithm in
order to detect
if the sales of the product or the
actual price of the
product was drawn compared to its past
average trend
for example if someone manually pressed
an extra zero for the sales then the
algorithm could flag
this as an atypical value and
also suggest the correction
moving on to healthcare we are currently
working with a big healthcare
organization
for which we are trying to find any
atypical behaving
doctors and patients our algorithm
helped us to find
doctors for example that perform
a routine procedure at a higher rate
than other doctors and also
for patients without chronic diseases
flacked a few patients that the average
visit frequency was
much higher than the rest of the
population
another example another project we
currently have
is the auditor's check this actual
algorithm
checks how our auditors work
what we mean by that because in the past
we noticed them some of our auditors
meaning the people that go and manually
collect data
from their assigned stores they were
cheating
they randomly put some numbers there or
because
they didn't have time to visit the store
they used the previous month's
information
and our algorithm tracked them and
flagged them and after investigate some
cases
further which were consistent some
people actually got fired
and finally the typical stores
project which we look in more detail in
the next steps
the algorithm here helped us to detect
detect a typical behaving stores and
also to provide with all the information
and the reasons
why they were flagged as a typical to
our end users
[Music]
a typical stores uh this project is
called is called
spotter the examples that i will go
through are applied
in a large retail chain that operates in
central
europe with more than 100 of
200 stores so imagine that we are
talking about
hundreds of millions of data that we had
to work with
in order to tackle this business problem
we had four questions and an answer
must were given to those
first of all we had to define the idea
behind the project
the idea was that we wanted to find
any typical spikes and drops
in the store's performance of that
change and then flag them
it was well defined that the method
we're going to use was an outlier
detection technique
our ultimate goal was obviously to find
the outliers
but also be able to provide all the
information
and all the story to our end users
in order to help them to make more
data-driven decisions
in order to improve their chain and
finally we built from scourge
our algorithm
moving on after we answered those four
questions
we started with the building process
first we had to use our raw data our raw
data were
daily transactions of this format
but we had to restructure them in a
format
that was going to keep only the
meaningful
information in order to get accurately
the outliers because the information was
on a daily basis we decided to aggregate
them
on a weekly basis the reason we chose to
focus on a weekly basis
was initially because for that specific
chain
the average visit frequency of its
shoppers
was within a week so the best way to
represent
a store's actual performance was
in a weekly time frame and another
reason we used
weekly data it was in order to be able
to inform our end users just
on time to make an action before it's
too late
and how to act
then the next step was to identify the
target variables that will help us
to define why a store was flagged as a
typical
the kit drivers were obviously
the sales the weekly sales of each store
the quantity that those stores sold
the products that were purchased and
also the number of baskets
and we looked in three into the three
different levels
at the store level at the category store
level and
the product store level
moving on to a key
stage it was the cleaning process
the purpose of the cleaning process is
was to ensure that we have
quality data before moving on to
building our algorithm
in order to remove the noise meaning the
false positives
and keep only the actual outliers we set
some constraints
for example constraints we we said where
to exclude any any recently open stores
and also to remove categories that
didn't have a lot of sales
so meaning they didn't impacted the
chain's overall
revenue in order to help our clients
to focus their attention on important
categories
and finally using r
we managed to build from scratch our
algorithm
while now it's trending to use more
complex procedures sometimes simple
statistics
can serve the purpose so that's why we
use
a combination of statistical and
rule-based approach
after we run our code and got our first
output we wanted to test it
with some obvious outliers to see if it
made sense
but something there it was missing
in order to improve our algorithm we
have to think
of some intermediate steps
currently the way they were the
algorithm worked it was comparing
the store with its own past history
so the first idea came to compare stores
uh to compare all the stores of the
chain
so for example let's say if it's if its
store was
over performing in a week then if we
compare it with other stores of the
chain for that week and we saw that
also those uh stores um
had the same trend then obviously the
alkalinity shouldn't flag them
as a typical but then
we thought about it again and we decided
to
um compare similar behavior stores
and the way we did that was using
hierarchical clustering
now let's see a bit of the steps we
followed
and the code
so as i said before
our data were aggregated weekly
and the columns here as we can see are
the each column is a store and each row
is a week and the values of the
aggregated weekly sales
we use those values and then calculated
the piece of correlation coefficient
of all the pairs of stores
so
let's move it a bit
so now let's look at the person
correlation coefficients
so this is our matrix with the
coefficients
then we use the h-class function from
the stats package
in order to calculate to produce our
hierarchical clustering
the endogram
let me show you the plot
of the denominator
you won't understand a lot because again
we are talking about hundreds of stores
but just to
give you an idea of the structure
and then a following step was to use
this dendogram as an input
to the dynamic tick cut package
this package has a lot of methods
sorry has a lot of methods
in order to define the final clusters
forward
and the only predefined
constraint we imposed was that each
cluster
should have a minimum of 30 stores
obviously this was adjusted for the
specific chain because it's a large one
if we for example we're focusing
applying this scenario on a smaller
chain then this number
should be adjusted and then finally
we have our our clusters
here you can see for each store the
assigned cluster
so now let's move on to
a part of our algorithm
an important part this is the part where
we defined if a store was
a typical or not the algorithm
is flux the stores for all the four
target variables i mentioned before but
in order to make this example a bit more
easy to understand let's focus only on
sales
and the same method applies for all the
target variables the method we used was
to build an acceptance range
using two case fences formula as shown
in the
picture below first of all
we print defined a a number
of past weeks for all the stores
we needed a history
and for that reason we split our periods
in short and in short and long term
periods
the purpose was in order to be able to
capture
any short or long term effects that the
target variables had
on the store's performance
moving on we calculated
the medians for both periods
for the weekly sales of each store
within the
the cluster the reason we use the
medians is because it's a robust metric
and it's not affected
by the extreme values that we have in
our data
moving on we also calculated the
median indices which
is an indication of the percentage
change between
the store's current weekly sales
and its median weekly sales
next in order to build our
acceptance range uh an upper and lower
bounds
were constructed so we used the first
and the third quantiles of the median
indices across
all the stores for the cluster again the
acceptance range
was calculated for both a short term and
a long term period
and finally any atypical values
any typical stores were detected
if their median index value
was outside the acceptance range
after we run our algorithm this is the
output we got
so for the week under evaluation for
each store and for each cluster
we found out if the store was a typical
for flux for any of the four target
variables
with a lot of excitement we went to
our clients and presented the whole
process the whole work we did
the hierarchical clustering the how we
compared stores
and how we decided to focus on specific
key drivers our target variables
and imag can you guess how many
uh to how many we sold this project
i don't know if we can answer or reply
in the chat
but just to make it short we sold none
so all the work we've done all the
clustering all the cleaning
or the building from scratch was useless
because as a company you always have to
think
that your clients don't have the same
expertise as you
so you have you have to find a bridge a
language
in which you can translate all this
information
in order for them to be able to make
inference and make more meaningful
and data-driven decisions
so we switch to
bi tools and we restructured
everything here let me
go to the actual dashboard
[Music]
so this is the dashboard our bi team
built which provides and has
all the information that the end user
needs in order to make
a data driven decision the user is
control
of the tool it has the flexibility to
see
for which categories a specific store
was flagged as a typical
over performer or underperformer which
products were sold or which
products were also a typical their past
history and many many many information
because
outliers these extreme values
have a lot of information and a story to
tell
so with the use of the bi tool we try to
capture
every part of the story and communicate
this to our clients
so closing with my part
uh a key point here is that
for us as uh data scientists
bi tools uh can't translate
a complex concept to non-technical
audience to surface meaningful and
actionable insights
so that's the end for the first part
i don't know if you have any questions
or we can move to my colleague andreas
and then
have your questions there at the q a
session at the end
thank you very much thank you very much
paulina thank you it was
on the talk really interesting and as
you said if there are any questions now
please open your mic and and ask them
i don't know if constantinos wants to
yeah can i add something
because most of the times we are
looking for an and an algorithm a
solution that helps everybody without
you know
have a software as a service make sure
that everyone has
we have a solution for every answer and
it's always the most accurate one
we sometimes have to have to compromise
some of the things in the
checks and of course if we are looking
to find outliers for a specific chain in
cyprus or in serbia or in
romania different cases can't be used
our biggest challenge though was to be
able like paulina said to
to translate the output of the algorithm
into actual business
execution so by showing that the story
is exceptional
the next question and the biggest
question is what what do they do with
that
uh for the algorithms that we have
internally
most of the times we automate the
procedure or we publish the output to a
specific person and we know what action
to take
but when we are talking about uh
automating and producing algorithms
for clients outside the company it's a
completely different level so
we actually need to be careful on
what we present um
and how we present the output
i see there's a question you found the
authorized based on the total
weekly sales and classes and then use
the bi delta
uh yes something like that when we found
the outliers
we not only use sales we used baskets we
use number of height terms number of
categories sold
um distribution of products prices
so like i said when you are saying that
this story is exceptional which has zero
percent
increase in in a week and you say that
is
exceptional we have to justify the
reason for that so by drilling down and
by
producing to the business the reasons
why we find it to be exceptional
it's maybe because if they have loyalty
cards for example maybe it's because
they reduced
the number of people going in so the
rest of the people buy more stuff
so the overall sales is stable but you
are losing people or they are maybe
buying from less categories so there is
a number of reasons and yes the the tool
has helped
if we are talking about a supermarket
having approximately between four
450 categories to 500
with an active product list of around 15
000 per year
you can imagine how many exceptions we
can have in every
week and we publish different results to
category managers different results to
store managers and and so on
so that's how we used it
i i had also one question for for
paulina
and it's it's about at some point
paulina you showed this uh
this very nice but quite dense dead
dendrogram that you mentioned
as well it's it's very dense i was
wondering whether you use also any
any i mean i guess in the process of
building an algorithm
whether you you and being aware that you
you have to do with a large amount of
data
whether you have any other visualization
tool
to help you not not when not when you
come to the let's say data product and
you you want to visualize it to the to
the client
and communicate but also internally to
help you
let's help you build these algorithms
um i'm not aware but i think
no i don't know if gustandino's also
theories can answer this
visual internally if you try to convince
saudis or andreas or polina to use a
visual
to identify the results 99 of the times
the answer is no so although we have
a couple of uh bi including uh the
sisense one and the power bi
and all these nice graphs and charts
uh sometimes sometimes we do publish our
results
through the bi because we have a
working environment internally we
publish in order to be able to see
what we are looking at but the way we do
it usually is we have
we have business people data scientists
that are involved in the business part
so we kind of split the work into uh
people that do the algorithm and people
that are more into the business and can
understand and
read the algorithms and then visualize
and take it
from there
[Music]
that example that paulina showed i
remember
the same with with the next chapter
chapter when we presented something in
excel seven years ago
they all started laughing and they
thought that you know we we sat down and
made that up
after six months of work they thought
that we we sit down in the
uh before we go into the meeting and
presented that
so sometimes not often but sometimes we
are talking about big projects yes we
use the same tools for the
that we have to publish for the clients
internally to visualize
uh our results
thank you are there are more questions
i have i have another one then it's it's
related to how you beat the
i mean in the process of beating an
algorithm i mean it's usually
uh somehow very customized procedure
according to the
you know the problem at hand and i was
wondering whether you follow
are there kind of um i mean in the
retail environment let's say are there
and is there a research done and
you follow parts of that or is it a
trial and error procedure
how do you go about that you know the
the most i remember when we were
discussing
internally exactly the same thing we we
asked
we gathered up together 10 15 people i
said okay you you will write an
algorithm
to correct the visitation of the auditor
so they go into the store they capture
the data for 30 days but some of them
instead of 30 days
they put 20 or 40 or 50. so
especially for the retail sector since
we have a lot of experience
the best way is is to start with a
statistician
uh empirically doing manually the work
so we try to track down whatever actions
they
they they do and we lock these actions
um internally for this specific example
we we now we output a database
not big let's say less than a million
lines
for a few categories only and we
challenge statisticians to say okay
identify manually what are the outlier
detections
in this database so without knowing
they started saying first of all i i
check out the share to do what to see if
it's important to the category or not
so this has to be documented in a way
that it's not specific to the database
by checking the
share to see the importance we're not
talking about if it's more
than 100 euros you have to you have to
write something that is relevant to a
bigger number of retailers so what does
it mean
relevant here uh if you have a hundred
products in the category it means more
than one percent if you have 50
so we start taking notes and and
and without knowing after two three
hours we had
three pages of comments of of
of alcorn so that was the first start
and we started
um putting this into
uh content from then on of course it's
it's more like because you apply this
into bigger data you find exceptions you
find
areas that doesn't work again we have a
set of eyes that checks the output
before going to the client
uh so that's how it's usually done
uh the other way if it's something new
um
you try to research and understand what
the rest of the
companies or what whatever exists out
there
in terms of packages and you start
checking on the
different data that you have internally
and you adjust you manipulate and then
you publish and go on
we have a lot of uh that was uh
at some point we had to decide whether
we go completely
as a software as a service or or we keep
that
custom-made solution uh it's it's more
difficult
to have everything custom but in in a
lot of cases
it has helped you know to make it more
precise
thank you if
there are no more questions
we can proceed with andreas
okay let's go all right
hi everyone
let me share
not yet
yes all right hi everyone
my name is andreas i work as a data
scientist at retail zoom
and the topic i'm going to talk about is
machine learning and business uh
more specifically i will talk about the
project that we are working on
it's called customer chair modelling
it's a project that it has been tried
before
in industries like telecom
uh i'll walk you through how did we
approach this
the methodology the steps we took and
at the end some of our conclusions
so what is chad well basically if
you are running a business and you have
some customers
then sometimes depending on the
situation
uh the customers have the option of
sharing of switching towards
your competitor
and therefore we can assume that
all customers have a probability of
journey
and when we talk about probability we
can approach this problem with machine
learning
a classification machine learning
project that we can
predict those probabilities
we're doing so by
building profiling for our customers
using transactional data and so
the question began became
given the profile of the customer can we
predict the
probability of cherny so that we can
take some actions and
prevent the churners from churning
the idea behind this project
was born to the fact that
it is way more expensive to acquire
customers
than it is to retain your existence
and the reason for that is because
if a customer is already being offered
something by your competitor then
offering the same is not enough you need
to offer much more in order to regain
the customer so it's kind of
buying their loyalty
um so the first thing we need to do was
to define some key variables
the first one is what actually is a
charger
um and this could be defined in a lot of
ways
uh for example the telecom
industry it's pretty much
straightforward um
each other is anyone that can't set the
the contract or will not
renew the contract at the end of its
period
um here in the in the retail industry
uh this definition can be defined in a
lot of ways um
because there's a lot of back and forth
between customers
some customers may be loyal to multiple
chains
and you can for example
define the chairman as anyone that does
not visit the
chain at all or you can define it as
anyone that visits and spends less
amount on x for example
um moving on we need to to build
the training data for our model we don't
actually own any
training data so um we need to build
in the and in the same way that our
observations
must answer the same question as we want
to answer
um later on we can do some feature
engineering some
um machine learning standard procedures
um then we can build our model
we can tune the model and then evaluate
the models
and we go back and forth a lot of times
until we decide
which motor to use
so i'm gonna show you how we built our
data
so first of all um we own some
transactional data
this is our raw data and what
transactional data
are uh you can think of
any observation on the transactional
data representing
a scan you make on the retail so
it has information about the product
it has a timestamp it has a unique
customer id
it has information about the sales and
the quantity
and therefore you can calculate the
price
it has information about promotion and
where
the in which store the the scan was made
so we need in order to build our
training data
um first of all we
needed to define another variable and
that is
we needed to answer the question who is
going to churn
within the next 10 days so
there's a kind of time frame here that
we need to define
um after we define it we take
depending depending on the volume of the
data we take
historical transactions and we split the
data into
equally time frame windows as our
um predefined periodicity
and then what we do is based on our
sharing definition we go within each
period and we can
assign who churn and who not
so for example um
without loss of generality let's assume
that
a chemner means that zero visits so
a customer will not visit at all
and and let's say that on on period 10
the customer a
did not visit we can go back to period 9
and assign
and say you know the customer rate will
change on the future on the next period
so this is how we created the our
response variable for our model
we then needed to create some external
variables
we've actually created a lot of them
that includes information about
sales volumes quantities
information about product attributes
like categories
visit frequencies days between visits
and baskets
and of course seasonality
procedurally what we did was we built
lots of
linear models we use the some important
variables to
try to identify the relationship between
those important variables with the trend
and the coefficients of that linear
models
is actually the relationship between
them and so we took those coefficients
and we included them as explanatory
variables
for our big model um
we've done some feature engineering
we've
created one column coding for our
category variables we've standardized
our numerical value
variables and then what we did we needed
to
clean our data so we needed to filter
out
some noisy data for example
some new cameras that we do not
own image much information about their
past
or we needed to filter out the already
lost
customers with very low visits or
spendings
because again the goal is to reach out
to the
customers that will get lost
and this is how we build our um model
data
now for the training of the model
we use the package called h2o
let me show you some code here
uh okay so h2o is an open source
platform
applicable both from rn python
it's not the best package for
deep learning it only supports
artificial neural networks but it has a
lot of variety of
supervised and unsupervised algorithms
so this is how right now i'm defining
i'm defining some variables and
splitting them into categorical and
numerical so that i can standardize my
numerical variables
and now i can initialize the page
upload the data into the platform
convert my response variable as being a
factor as a class
i'm then going to split my data into
training set
validation set and test set and then
we did at the beginning we
uh run a lot of um we've had a lot of
hours of
training and and testing and it also
supports the option of photo machine
learning so it builds
it goes through a variety of algorithms
and builds models and
gives you the better models so what
we've noticed was that
um the algorithm gradient boosting
machine the gbm
was most of the time performing better
than
any other other algorithm so we decided
to stay in that
and do some hyper parameter tuning
so here i'm defining some
a cartesian type parameter space
and then i have the option of either go
through
all the parameters combinations or
just do a random search um if you go
with
option two then you need to add an
argument on
when to stop searching so right now i'm
just gonna put
three models just to end up this
quickly
this is how i'm defining my my algorithm
i'm defining
what i'm going to use my variables
response and explanatory variables my
training and validation set
um so as you can see here it has the
performance but um
it runs pretty much first it uses java
to train the models
and then you can print and sort
your models based on an evaluation
metrics
of your choice so right now i'm creating
the
three models that it builds it tells you
what type of parameters used and the
corresponding evaluation metrics
now for the production part what we did
was
um we built some automated data capture
system
that at the end of each period you
automatically capture the latest
transaction it could
converts the data into training data
it builds from scratch another model and
it immediately predicts for the upcoming
period
we load the data into
[Music]
to bi2 where our clients can
filter based on their probability of
being chair
and they can investigate their
historical and
historical purchasing habits
we also have an execution execution tool
where again we load the data
and again we can filter the risky
customers
and reach them by personal campaigns
with products they like to buy your
recommended products
now i know that for every data scientist
the motivation when doing machine
learning is
the performance of our models
we can spend a lot of days and hours and
weeks to have a better model
but sometimes in the business we are
missing the
bigger picture and that is the
data and results interpretability
so we need to the real challenge here is
to convince our clients that this is
actually a meaningful results
that they can trust and
you somehow you need to find a way to
convert your knowledge
into people that you know having enough
knowledge on machine learning no
statistics or mathematics
um okay that that's it for the project
uh
we'll now have a q a session and feel
free to drop your questions
i think thank you very much andrea
any questions
i can start with one um andrea you
mentioned that you are
of course using a lot of transactional
data
that i understand that these these data
are used to
to train the models um
i was wondering whether um so what's the
let's say the average amount of data
you you handle
to train one one of such models
or the order of this of this volume
yeah so basically that depends on the on
the retailer
for example if we are talking about the
cyprus retailer we can have
as big as half a million or even some
more
of historical
training data and when we go out to
bigger chains on the on other countries
bigger countries
we can even have as much as a million
historical uh no transactional data
training data
yeah and that's for the so for for what
kind of time period are these are these
data for
like on a daily basis
yeah so um we took for example
let's say that we can take two years of
transactional data
and we split the data for example
on a monthly basis so we can see on each
month
future and who not and
we can our real prediction will be on
the
on the next month
and how how does the
[Music]
the amount of data translate to let's
say
memory also is it in order of gigabyte
or
or how how much is this translated to
um right now i'm not sure
i'm not i'm asking just to understand
whether whether you can fit this
down on your workstation on your laptop
yeah i think one one giga amp for a
million
something like that okay
so you are on the edge let's say to use
them on on
one laptop or one good workstation
usually we are we are using a
workstations
okay
can i add something on the
[Music]
on the overall risky project uh
the risky has always been considered as
something that we
publish a percentage to our clients
let's say
that these people have 97 or 77
probability to share
in different industries
we have different interpretations of the
percentage
so for example we are into a project now
with a betting
company so you can understand a person
that bets
a thousand euros and he has ninety
percent probability of churning
this thousand euros is a complete loss
for the company
whereas if we are talking about in a
supermarket where the
percentage of
profit is is much smaller uh
different actions uh required the same
applies when we are talking about
what is actually the probability to
chair does it mean that
these people disappear the next day
from the supermarket or from the
cosmetic chain
if someone spends an amount of
let's say an average family with two
kids spends between 500
400 and 600 euros so if they spend that
continuously every month and we
consider them to be 90 risky and they
actually spend 30 euros next month
which is actually something they are
still consider as
churners now the
the the way we enhanced and we converted
it into an
outlier detection module is the fact
that
when we predict the probability we need
to also justify
why these people are risky so
if if someone is risky because they
reduce the
the frequency or they reduce the average
basket size they reduce their quantity
or
different variants we need to
communicate that to the client because
they need to take different action
i remember during the
a few years back when we had the
huge fall of the banks and everybody was
spending less
the first thing we noticed is that we if
we used
the sales we noticed that a lot of
people had a huge decrease on sales
but the quantity was actually not
changed so
by taking we had to switch from sales to
quantity
in order to make sure that people still
bought 100 products but they bought
cheaper products or another example was
that
when people started spending
they went more frequently and they spend
in order
in order not to go once every month and
spend 500 euros
they went 10 times and they spent 50
euros
the actual result on the sales of the
month was
they didn't spend 50 euros precisely
every period so they spent 51.52
so at the overall expenditure of the
month they went up
they actually increased more money they
spent more money in the chain
so we needed to communicate that they
are risky because they change that habit
they are buying less categories so
they're probably buying
toothpaste someplace else but the
overall money is
is fine they are still spending with you
so you don't like
so the actual the actual
explanation of the in terms of
what the percentage mean is where we use
different variables to explain to the
customer
there are some questions also in the in
the chat one yes
yes i guess and the last question has
more to do so
uh i can read it so we have it also
please for everybody
so concerning the promotional strategies
so andreas asks and kpis based on models
could this work uh could this work on an
associate societal level with project
related dissemination and outreach
activities
given that we have meaningful statistics
from the population of a country or
countries or aggregates
example given balkans and if so how much
and what type of data would we need to
use to train models in order to have a
good approximation
and i guess that the question has to do
with the amount of data needed to
to train a model and have meaningful to
have a meaningful model uh
i assume okay that's a bit tricky
because for every especially with promos
[Music]
promotional strategies and kpis
we have a lot of times you know you know
being asked how you
you train a model with the information
that we've we've given
so the we need to have a the most
important thing is to have the whole
of the actions affecting
a specific project
so the definition of the product project
what we are trying to achieve at the end
of the day
we need to make a very good
analysis on which variables we need to
use promotional
strategies and promotional activities
for example
the reason that is very complicated and
sometimes no matter how many data we use
is
because there are always factors that
affect your own
data and your own performance that we
are not driven by you
so again we come to the conclusion
how accurate the model is uh of course
we can use these activities and the
statistics and the population
of the countries and so on
[Music]
the more information the more
[Music]
the better the approximation will be
but we've seen that if you want
something
quite accurate you need to spend a lot
of time
and a lot of money uh which most of the
times becomes
you know irrelevant for the for the
companies and
not willing to pay for that
um what else is it
described in the question did we answer
or not
i think andreas can tell us about the
thing i think i would say yes
and there is another there is another
question from julie
let me read this loud as well i know
that so this has unanswered
it or part of it but let's let's say it
out loud so julie asks if
if have you had the opportunity to test
the added value of such models by doing
an analysis
one year after implementing the solution
whether the actions to reduce the churn
you predicted actually worked
for example yes okay another good
question
there is always a how do you
how do you test whether these are churns
or not
and how do you test what action they
have taken because when we provide a
churn chern is part of the
of the overall crm project so we have a
lot of
actions going on at the same time the
best way to check
is at a specific point of time when you
would you do a test and control
and group and you manage to see the
impact of the results you have done at a
specific point in time if you
if you wait a year to check whether this
people actually responded we're talking
about
thousands of promotions uh points on the
card
uh communications leaflets for one
another purpose so it's quite difficult
to
um understand
whether there was one reason behind the
non-churners
or two uh we definitely noticed
uh that if you do nothing
and you lose them uh it's much more
difficult to get them back
whereas if you do something quite
quickly
when you have a probability that's why i
said before
we are discussing today internally
whether we keep usually models keep
probabilities more than 50 percent
but if i have a customer that spends
1 000 euro in a supermarket and he has
49
probability to chair i'm not going to
let that guy go
and wait for the probability to go
eighty percent because then it becomes
more and more difficult to offer
something
uh to get them back so
it definitely does work and
and one way we check it anyway is we
predict the previous month
from the previous month when we actually
have daytime tested
and a very big difference again with the
with the clients is some clients
uh consider different
let's say thresholds for a customer to
become a chairman
so something that for you might be
considered a churner
for the customer is not and the other
way around
this year is it's been very difficult to
test with all these
corona stuff we had increase in toilet
paper by 120 percent
we had increase in pasta by a hundred
percent we've seen the consumption of
um specific categories and grow
by huge numbers so we are trying to be
a bit careful of whether we consider
someone
to have a success on the actions we've
made
or not
thank you thank you guys for that for
the nice answers for the very formative
answers
any more questions
okay then
if we have no more questions then
let's thank again paulina andreas
gossantinos and every one of you that
you attended
it was it was a really nice event and we
really thank you for that
and and uh as always uh
please reach to us if you want to give a
talk and
we will be in the slack channel if you
want to
ask more questions to retail zoom uh
some of them will be inside and they
might be able to
uh to discuss with you and answer more
questions
thank you very much thank you very much
for having us
thank you very much thank you
you